toujours dans l'actualité internationale
c'est demain que nicolas sarkozy entame
une visite en syrie
une page se tourne ce rapprochement est
un pari un pari français car la syrie il
faut le rappeler était considéré il ya
quelques mois encore comme un état voyou
allié de l'iran soutenant le hezbollah
alors à quoi ressemble ce pays
aujourd'hui est-il en train d'évoluer
la poigne de fer du régime al-assad
va-t-elle se desserrer regardez le
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux renaud
bernard et pascal caron à 8 heures du
matin il fait déjà 40 degrés mais après
des années d'isolement damas respire le
régime est redevenu fréquentable
bachar al-assad et son épouse asma
incarnerait t-il renouveau il ya dix ans
sous la dictature de son père hafez el
assad
on parlait des années de plomb ici l'air
frais sur du transistor tous les jours
cogner un line la libre antenne
impensable il ya quelques années elle
discute avec les auditeurs et la liberté
de ton séduit ainsi rien sur deûle
écoute à la radio
il faut aborder tous les sujets la
sexualité des abus sexuels
les addictions de toutes sortes même la
drogue c'est la liberté pouvoir faire ça
vraiment c'est la liberté la liberté
pour les syriens le concept reste
relatif à 24 ans diana est une jeune
cadre prospère elle gagne 4 fois le
salaire moyen
comme ses amis qu'elle invite
régulièrement chez elle
jeunesse privilégié de la masse
officiellement tout va bien pour eux
maintenant vraiment on peut faire tout
ce qu'on veut
nv comment on veut mais il reste quand
même certains minitab au con con avoir
de pas lequel la politique ça reste
dangereux de critiquer le régime
mais il y à internet et ses sites
prohibés comme facebook
quant aux blogs cet été ils ont conduit
cinq jeunes en prison mais ça n'empêche
pas leur fréquentation
de toute façon avec les technologies
modernes si on veut accéder à un site on
trouve toujours un chemin à l'ombre de
la mosquée des omeyyades
les syriens semblent donc s'émanciper
mais rien ne serait possible sans l'aval
du président commente un proche de
bachar al assad
moi je dirais à un certain moment la
série était un régime totalitaire c'est
pas une dictature c'est plutôt un elton
régimes totalitaires et qui c'est qui
est enfin maintenant de se transformer
métamorphose est très profondément donc
bientôt
souvenez vous disiez
je l'espère même selon amnesty
international il y aurait encore 1500
prisonniers politiques en syrie
petit à petit bachar al assad émancipe
la syrie à une exception près pas
d'ouverture politique
le président vient d'annoncer qu'il va
bientôt autoriser la création de partis
d'opposition
mais pour le moment ceux qui critiquent
le régime et risquent toujours d'être
jeté en prison
et ce soir l'elysée annonce la probable
signature de nouveaux contrats
d'exploration et d'exploitation de
pétrole pour total en syrie